I'm Ben Dominic I'm Ainsley Earhart I'm
Trey Gowdy and this is the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
Wednesday October 12 2022 Alisa
break a campaign issue hits home with a
shooting outside a candidate's home one
of the main reasons why I got into this
race was because I feel like much more
needs to be done to take back our
streets I'm Dave Anthony
Russia's leader is increasingly
targeting civilians in Ukraine he cannot
defeat the will of the Ukrainian people
and think that they're still trying it
after eight months just gives you a
sense of how pitiful their ability to
make assessments are and how poorly
their intelligence system truly is and
I'm Tommy lahren I've got the final word
on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
the Sprint to election day begins but
the gloves were already off in the New
York governor's race and on the day our
Capital was attacked a day that led to
the deaths of five Brave police officers
zeldin still voted to overturn the
election that ad trying to link
Republican Congressman Lee zeldin to
president Trump and calling him extreme
and dangerous on issues including
abortion while ads supporting zeldan
accused the Democratic incumbent of
being corrupt also calling out her time
as lieutenant governor before Governor
Andrew Cuomo resigned we all know the
Cuomo scandals and right there with
Cuomo is Kathy hokel the silent
accomplice New York is considered a deep
blue State and the latest Fox News Power
Rankings put the governor's race in the
solid D category good news for hokel but
zeldin says the issues that got him into
the race haven't changed and now one of
them crime has literally landed on his
doorstep my girls were definitely
traumatized by the experience while the
congressman and his wife were out
campaigning on Sunday two teenagers were
injured in a drive-by shooting outside
his house on Long Island his twin
sixteen-year-old daughters were home at
the time on top of hearing the gunshots
during the screaming they thought that
these individuals who were near our
front door were targeting them we're
trying to get inside of the house so
they ran upstairs they locked themselves
in the bathroom they called 9-1-1 and
they had no idea what was going on
outside of that bathroom door so for
them at 16 years old just sitting there
on a Sunday afternoon doing their
homework and then all of this suddenly
out of nowhere starts happening it was a
pretty traumatic experience for them
they responded very swiftly very smartly
they instantly were upstairs locked in
the bathroom calling 9-1-1 they were
with me yesterday at the Columbus Day
Parade in Manhattan and they're next to
me while I was answering some questions
from some of the media that was there
and then one of the questions got
directed at one of them and this was the
first time that they were doing an
interview like this with media
and they've just showed tremendous Poise
they were articulate it's very scary and
we didn't know if they were coming after
us they were genuine in explaining what
they had experienced with their emotions
were what they saw what they felt
they've just been very strong and I'm
very grateful for my wife and our family
is very happy that this didn't come out
any worse than it did but uh you know
coming home with crime scene tape around
my own house being told to be careful
where I'm walking towards my front door
because they want to make sure that I'm
not stepping on blood was a scene that
when I left the house that morning I
obviously absolutely was not expecting
to be returning home to
had you been planning already to bring
your daughters to the parade with you
as far as my wife and daughter's a
decision that they might make the night
before or the morning of uh depending on
what kind of work they have how they're
feeling so just like many other events
that was something for them to decide
the night before or the morning of
whether or not they would come with me
the night before this is Sunday night
after the shooting they wanted to stay
in our bedroom so the four of us stayed
in the bedroom with my wife and I and
the next morning we decided that we
would have the girls join us and that's
something that they absolutely wanted to
the police have said this shooting
wasn't targeting your family but it is
the second violent incident during your
run for governor after a man tried to
stab you during a campaign speech
fighting crime has been one of your
themes in in this election do these
incidents help make that case what do
you hear on the campaign Trail
well as I travel around the state I hear
from a lot of New Yorkers who are
greatly concerned about Rising crime
that they want to see more support of
men and women in law enforcement they
want some of these pro-criminal laws
like Castle spell to be rolled back they
want to see District Attorneys actually
doing their job there's a lot of support
out there as it's being discussed the
option to remove the Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg the Constitutional
Authority that's given to a governor
here in New York where we don't have
recall elections so one of the main
reasons why I got into this race was
because I feel like much more needs to
be done to take back our streets and
whether it's cashless Bell that needs to
be overhauled to give judges discretion
the way dangerousness or repealing the
halt act because our Corrections
Officers are being assaulted more and
there's Discovery Law changes that need
to be rolled back there's a number of
other lower profile laws that also are
adversely impacting Safety and Security
on our streets and there's just a lot
more high profile crimes that are taking
place right now in New York I mean just
look at what's happened over the course
of the last week or two and that list
has a feel as if you're going through a
list of high-profile crimes from the
last year or two so I will obviously
you'll be sharing the mother killed last
week in front of her three kids because
of the cashless Bell Law not keeping her
husband detained and the person was
released the day before and some of
these other crimes that we're seeing
like a guy taking an ax out of his
backpack at the McDonald's on Delancey
Street in lower Manhattan swinging at
tables and walls and customers and then
instantly released due to Casual spell
I'll tell those stories and I obviously
you know have a strong personal
connection that dates back to being
raised in a a law enforcement household
my running mate I just retired with
nearly 25 years of experience in the
NYPD and was a commanding officer of the
70th Precinct in Brooklyn now we're
going to talk about all of this and why
we believe strongly that there's a need
for this change to be able to take back
our streets
Governor Kathy Hogle has said the
shooting outside your house when she was
asked about it she said it shows the
need to work together to get guns off
the streets I will continue as I've been
on this journey as Governor to do
everything we can to ensure that our
streets are safe that is one of my
highest priorities I know you've been
critical of the State's new gun
restrictions which were changed recently
after being struck down in court and
they're still being challenged in court
Democrats outnumber Republicans by a lot
in New York state though so is that a
losing issue for you
well first off there's still more that
needs to be known about who the shooters
were what their motives were
now Kathy hokel has called on American
Express and MasterCard and visa to flag
all gun purchases as suspicious and the
argument that I made when she first made
that call that I would highlight here
while we still wait for more information
about the shooting that took place
outside my home on Sunday afternoon it
probably did not start with a swipe of
an American Express card the person who
was the shooter was probably not a
concealed carry permit holder obviously
the person who did it wasn't a
law-abiding Yorker looking to safely and
securely carry a firearm solely for
self-defense so the problem was that the
week after the United States Supreme
Court overturned New York's
unconstitutional concealed carry law she
went so far in passing a new law where
everyone woke up on a Friday morning and
there was no bill by that afternoon they
were having a bill signing and they were
infringing all over First Amendment
rights to trample all over second
amendment rights it was obvious that
their new law was going to get
overturned by the courts it was just a
matter of weeks it was in fact
unconstitutional so what we should be
doing is that everybody should be
working together to go after criminals
carrying illegal Firearms committing
Crime After Crime After Crime and
they're still out on the streets what we
shouldn't be doing is targeting
law-abiding New Yorkers who want to
safely securely carry a firearm solely
for self-defense so that aspect of it
has been one of the very biggest
disconnects of this debate New York
already has the strictest gun control
laws and obviously that didn't stop a
gang-related drive-by shooting at my own
house just two days ago
abortion is another issue where the
governor could maybe argue that public
opinion is with her at least in New York
there have been ads running for months
calling you extreme on the issue of
abortion how do you counter that
well here's her problem is that when New
Yorkers woke up the day after the Dobbs
decision the law in New York was exactly
the same as it was the day before
nothing changed a comet didn't change
and I'm not going to roll that back but
she's trying to create an issue but that
doesn't change the reality that New York
they've codified far more than row and
it doesn't change the reality then I'm
not going to roll that back there's a
less than zero percent chance that the
Democrats who control the New York State
Assembly are going to send me a bill
rolling that law back so what we should
be doing is actually talking about the
issues that New Yorkers are saying are
the most important shoes to them and the
issues are focused around the breaking
point of a New Yorker who's deciding
whether or not to stay here New York
leads the entire nation in population
loss and the reason is is because they
feel like their wallet and their safety
and their freedom the quality of their
kids education are under attack and
they're looking at other states and they
feel like their money will go further
they will feel safer they will live life
Freer we have to be acknowledging that
and talking about what we are going to
do to reverse it and the fact that Kathy
hokel doesn't want to talk about the
High Cost of Living about cashless fail
and va's who refusing to do their jobs
and What needs to get done to restore a
balance in Albany to support our men and
women in law enforcement more and make
the streets of New York safer the fact
is she doesn't want to talk about her
pay-to-play scandals and all the
corruption the way that she's raised
tens of millions of dollars for her
campaign and it's very telling to the
people in New York that she's trying to
get away with just one cable debate for
one hour at the very end of October over
a month after the start of absentee
mail-in voting we should be having
multiple debates around the state about
all of these issues but instead she just
wants to hide behind TV attack ads and I
believe that voters deserve to know
where we stand on issues before they
vote not after
with a month left do you change your
strategy at all do you stay the course I
know it's an uphill battle in New York
just by the Numbers it's been I think
two decades since a republican won a
Statewide race in New York do you stay
the course do you change strategy what
do you do with these remaining weeks
I entered this race just over a year and
a half ago April 8th 2021 my strategy
today is exactly the same as it was when
I first got into this race the only
thing that changed that was significant
was who we were running against when I
got into this race Andrew Cuomo was
still in the office he then resigned but
the issues that we're talking about and
the importance that New Yorkers put
behind wanting to know what we're going
to do to make life in New York more
affordable wanting to know what we're
going to do to make the streets of New
York safer are actually even more of an
issue now than they were then so what we
were talking about when we entered into
this race in many respects are even more
important than how important these
issues were when we first got in New
York Republican congressman and
gubernatorial candidate Lee zeldin thank
you so much for your time good luck with
the campaign thank you so much great to
be with you
this is Tommy lahren with your Fox News
commentary coming up
there's been a lot of this in Ukraine
that's in.nets cause Russia has carried
out dozens of bombings the past few days
many times targeting residential areas
we don't know what to do or where to
live let all the world see what they did
here there have been more than a hundred
casualties Ukraine's Ambassador Sergey
kazlitzia told the U.N by launching
missile attacks on civilians
sleeping in their homes or rushing to
work children going to schools Russia
has proven once again that it is a
terrorist state that must be the third
Ukraine's President says they will not
be intimidated and in a video conference
with President Biden and other G7 Nation
leaders Vladimir zielinski asked for
more air defense support the G7 put out
a statement condemning Russia's attacks
as a war crime and they'll hold Russia's
leader accountable Vladimir Putin calls
the attack's retaliation for the bombing
of a bridge to Crimea over the weekend
if attempts to carry out acts of
terrorism on our territory continue
Russia's response will be harsh and its
scale will correspond to that of the
threat made against the Russian
Federation what Putin is doing not a
surprise to Fox News senior strategic
analyst for eight months Putin
and his generals have been trying to
defeat the Ukraine Army and they have
failed miserably at it General Jack
Keane is a retired four-star general
former Vice Chief of Staff of the U.S
army and chairman of the institute for
the study of War now they're resorting
to defeat the Ukrainian people the focus
on the civilian population and also to
focus on the energy sector to try to
bring the electric grid down and and
also interrupt the gas supply so that
the Ukrainian people as butcher
approaches and it starts to embed itself
in their society that they suffer quite
a bit this is all an attempt by Putin to
break the will of the Ukrainian people
something he has always adopted as an
objective for his military force to
break their will and force zielinski to
surrender as a result of that General
you talked about doing this before
winter The Invasion started during the
last winter why would it have taken this
long to go after these particular energy
sectors gas lines wouldn't you have
assumed they would start with that right
away back then
yeah well then they were also attempting
to defeat a deployed Ukrainian military
so the focus was clearly on that a very
distant secondary effort was to deal
with the grid and the population itself
after all they thought that once they
introduced their artillery into the
dombas region and they had some success
with it they actually believed that they
were going to be able to roll up the
rest of the South and be able to fulfill
their occupation but what happened to
them is they took so many casualties he
knows that the forces he has deployed in
Ukraine are insufficient to be able to
dominate and take control of Ukraine's
military and its territory and that is
why he's gone to a mobilization he
actually wants to double the amount of
forces in in Ukraine it's around 200 000
and remember he's had 25 000 killed 65
000 wounded during these eight months
and that's why he's trying to get these
Replacements in as quickly as he can but
when we analyze it at the institute for
the study of War while numbers will
always help and you can't be dismissive
of the fact that if you bring in you
dump the amount of forces there's going
to be some benefit to that but in terms
of Effectiveness as a military
organization we don't see it as being
decisive and Russia will have the same
problems going forward with the Ukraine
military that they're having now yeah
and and you talked about mobilization if
he brings all these people into service
some have no training whatsoever or they
had fought years ago
many of them don't want to go there have
been people who've left the country fled
don't want to be and there have been
protests I mean this hasn't helped
the Russian leader in his own country he
seems less popular am I wrong or right
the Russian people obviously know now
things are not going well in Ukraine
they may not know all the details that
we do because they don't get a daily
Narrative of it but they know things
aren't going well and that's why this
mobilization is taking place but to go
to Ukraine a country that they actually
have a relationship with the people that
they actually like and they go there to
vacation at times they get away from
Russia to go to Odessa or Crimea and now
to have the young people in Russia go to
Ukraine to risk their life to kill
ukrainians there is no stomach for that
you're absolutely right so this force is
going to show up with no commitment to
deal with this remember in the very
beginning the Russian military was very
deceptive with their units about why
they were mobilizing they were told they
were being mobilized for training
purposes many of them did not know they
were going to war and it's not
surprising that pitiful results that
came as a result of that now there was a
New York Times story that talked about
how hardliners in Russia
they applaud
what Vladimir Putin has done the last
couple of days the strategy of going
after residential areas one of them was
quoted as as saying that that we need to
scare ukrainians into submission and
really the in order to do that you have
to be really really violent
can Vladimir Putin do what he thinks he
can do scaring them no
he cannot defeat the will of the
Ukrainian people and to think that
they're still trying it after eight
months just gives you a sense of how
pitiful their ability to make
assessments are and how poorly their
intelligence system truly is after all
this time if they don't understand the
will of the Ukrainian people they are
fundamentally missing the basic Point
here I spoke to the Ukrainian ambassador
to the United States on Friday with her
defense out of Shay I just wanted to
know you know what they really wanted so
I could help them publicly we got to
talking about nuclear weapons and the
potential and and the rest of it I think
that potential is relatively Low by the
way but the Ambassador spoke up and said
you know even if a nuclear weapon was
used in Ukraine she said we're not going
to quit we are going to continue to
fight despite the casualties we will not
give up on land to the Russians we will
fight them to the end yeah and Ukraine
that counter-offensive continues they've
taken back some Villages some towns in
those regions that Russia Annex claiming
now as part of Russia which makes kind
of an odd twist I mean Vladimir Putin
could claim now that Ukraine's invading
him oddly yeah of course that's what he
wants people to think I mean he's
certainly not discussing the fact that
he actually suffered a military defeat
and in all four of those regions as you
noted first of all he doesn't own any
single one of them completely number two
and two of them the ukrainians are
taking territory from the Russians and I
can tell you for a fact and it's well
documented that they're planning to
conduct operations in the third in
separisia where the famous nuclear plant
is and drive that operation all the way
to the city of mariopol which they lost
a few months ago so yes they're planning
even more significant Channel are
offensives known full well that they've
got the Russians back on their heels of
course the US is a big part of this we
have been sending money we have been
sending weapons ammunition and again
there's a new call Tuesday from the
president of Ukraine urging the U.S and
our allies to send air defenses all some
have questioned if the U.S is doing too
much and the Ally is not enough what do
you think well we're doing about 75
percent of it for sure but we also have
the most significant capacity by far one
of the things our audience likely
doesn't understand
is just how far the European military
capability has atrophy I mean we're
talking about France only having two
divisions we're talking about the Brits
having won
the Germans have even less than that and
then the other militaries fall off as
well so the capacity isn't what it
should be but there is some Fair
criticism the Germans and the French
could considerably do more than what
they're doing and listen so people
understand there's some that are saying
well we're spending too much money uh
you know we're up to around 17 billion
dollars or so but a lot of that money is
going to Hughes defense contractors to
build these weapons that's American jobs
being executed someplace in the in the
United States depending on the company
and that's not really been brought out
very clearly now back to that statement
from G7 leaders it reaffirmed if Russia
uses chemical biological or nuclear
weapons that would be met with severe
consequences President Biden told a
Democratic fundraiser last week Vladimir
Putin is not joking and we're at the
closest point now to nuclear Armageddon
since the 1962 civil Soviet Union Cuban
Missile Crisis general Keane's reaction
he's prone to exaggeration and he has a
tendency at times to dramatize things I
think he's out of fundraising and he he
wants there's empathy and their support
I mean if he was serious about
Armageddon then why is he not making a
speech from the Oval Office about an
existential threat to the United States
that presidents have not faced in
decades and why is he not going to the
Congress seeking legislative support
which would be overwhelmingly bipartisan
likely no one would oppose it in
condemning Russia's threat of using
nuclear weapons on the surface of it
doesn't make any sense but you have to
take it seriously and I think the
administration will give them at face
value they have indicated they have
talked to the Russian leaders and told
them there would be catastrophic
consequences and they have so all about
what they are and I'll take that as what
they have done then the Russians issue
is we know the United States has the
capability to do that and what we're
likely talking about is an air and
missile attack on Russian forces inside
of Ukraine they know we have that
capability they know NATO does and the
issue for them is is Biden believable is
he credible so you think Vladimir Putin
if he were to use some sort of a nuclear
weapon would be calculating that
President Biden wouldn't still want
would still want not to have direct
conflict with him that's correct but I
think as military generals would have a
different Viewpoint they would likely
come to the conclusion that the United
States and NATO doesn't have any choice
using a nuclear weapon inside of Europe
is something that the United States and
NATO uh could not ignore because if they
did then Putin's got nuclear blackmail
in his Hip Pocket the pressure of Poland
the pressure to Baltic states you know
to revive his entire campaign to get
back the Soviet republics Under the
Umbrella of the Russian Empire again it
would give them a hand to play and I
just don't think realistically that the
United States and NATO could ever sit on
their hands and ignore something like
that General Jack Keane retired
four-star general former Vice Chief of
Staff of the U.S army chairman of the
institute for the study of war and Fox
News senior strategic analyst thank you
as always for joining us yeah delighted
to be with you and your audience
appreciate it
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
my name is Kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will I humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's Kennedy Saves the World
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com trade and review the
Fox News rundown on Apple podcasts or
wherever you listen it's time for your
Fox News commentary
what's on your mind New Jersey will be
the first state to mandate a climate
change curriculum for K-12 students and
said to be necessary to prepare for the
green economy perhaps we should get
students proficient at Reading Writing
and arithmetic before demanding they
learn about climate change but
furthermore this all feels a lot more
political than educational something
tells me this climate change curriculum
is more about leftist agenda pushing
than actual science if they want to
teach students about the pitfalls of
fossil fuels they should also mention
how many Americans rely on fossil fuels
and how many well-paying jobs that
industry Fosters and if we want to talk
about the economic aspect of climate
change I hope these educators will
mention canceling the Keystone Pipeline
has done nothing to save the environment
or lessen emissions but it has made us
more dependent on foreign energy sources
but I'm guessing that part won't be in
the textbooks huh I'm Tommy lahron and
you can listen to all my hot takes at
foxnewscommentary.com
[Music]
casts.com and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
put the power of over 100 meteorologists
and a worldwide resources of fox in your
hands with the fox weather podcast
precise personal powerful subscribe and
listen now at foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes